[Music]
all right my friends I have planned an
amazing and awesome day for us and
that's what I'm talking about Brooke
Siri play la mix thank you it's because
we're in LA and it's
are you gonna take us to get green juice
and clothes
so this is the Blind Barber it's pretty
secret it's a barber shop but you can
get a taco here what's up guys what's up
man how are you nice to see you
alright follow me down the creepy
hallway but voila
right a fully functioning bar thank you
so much thank you
look at these almost want to name them
come on Roberto making it on tap with my
mouth sweet sweet Beatrice this is
unbelievable
alright I want to take you guys to the
ultimate grilled cheese truck they're a
little hard to find but we'll just look
them up online and then we'll be on our
way
all right I got it right here great all
right let's do it to it did you just say
do it do it yes I did
all right here we are oh it's go to the
parking lots to eat okay all right so
this place is known for a fully loaded
cheese eat back and read no question
John it's on the house yeah all right
there's mac and cheese inside of a
grilled cheese yeah they're my life
really about their life well what about
your bat mitzvah
[Music]
all right pals here we are at our bar I
know it's you know a bar and the Sun
still is out but this place has the best
wings in Los Angeles okay before we dig
in let's take a moment of silence and
bow our heads and we can reflect on the
adventure that we had today here in the
best city in the world regardless of
what you guys think come on man so those
were all my hidden gems of Los Angeles
what do you guys think the food was
pretty good but it's nothing to compare
to the pizza in Chicago
what No everybody knows that Pete's in
New York is the best Los Angeles has
some pretty good pizza
[Music]